i've compared it with radical islam
you know they want to shut down free
inquiry
you have those who are in and those who
are out
um they are willing that you know they
don't want to have a conversation with
you they want to destroy you
they they they divide a society
into subsets of groups they deny
objective truth
they're hostile to science hey by the
way
they say they are standing up for women
and gays and transgender people and so
on but
if you look at what they're saying
they're actually the most racist
misogynistic people in the world
so i know things actually aren't that
bad although we've got a certain set of
problems but i do sense that
liberalism itself seems to be being
destroyed right now that woke-ism has
destroyed the
at the academic level uh what you're
seeing at all all of the institutions
that liberalism is in a particularly
tough spot you are absolutely right
uh liberalism by the way is uh it's it's
i would i i'd say it's probably one of
the youngest
of um philosophies and classical
liberalism
and from the time that the enlightenment
and classical liberalism emerged
it has always been under threat
and there's this beautiful golden age
time when it
um it triumphed and but that triumph was
um it was like a back and forth uh
you know we we only had the first and
second world wars
um in the 20th century right in that
century when
things seemed people seemed to be
attracted to reason
and i think this is not going to stop um
liberalism
is once again challenged now obviously i
was really very much
engaged as you know from my background
with
the challenges that political islam
presents
and the the narrative of political islam
is
liberalism is wrong individualism
is wrong universalism is wrong and only
the way they
see and the utopia of their goals is the
right way
and that the way you achieve that is
through violence sacrifice
um through misogyny and through all
sorts of other
affronts to the idea and philosophy of
liberalism
now what's interesting with the work
ideology is that it is actually
a byproduct of liberalism that it is a
disappointment
with the world and so if you read that
book i i sent it to everybody i could
send it to
cynical theories i haven't i have it
i've had james on yeah
i too i would say modern day liberals
um helen black rose and james lindsey
what they're trying to show us is that
if you dig
deep and that's what they've done dig
deep into the philosophies that inform
what we now call walkism cancer culture
critical theory
critical race theory it goes by many
names
but that is an unintended consequence of
liberalism appointment with modernity
it's a
disappointment with civilization it's a
yearning for some kind of utopia
it does use secular
arguments and underpinnings but it does
have a religious
quality to it
i i've i've compared it with radical
islam
you know they want to shut down free
inquiry
you have those who are in and those who
are out
um they're willing that you know they
don't want to have a conversation with
you they want to destroy you
they they they divide a society
into subsets of groups they deny
objective truth
they're hostile to science hey by the
way
they say they are standing up for women
and
gays and transgender people and so on
but if you look at what they're saying
they're actually the most
racist misogynistic people in the world
and so in that sense i would say here's
a new challenge
to liberalism it shouldn't surprise us
if you're a true classical liberal
you know that
the challenges ideological philosophical
challenges to liberal
artists place they'll stay with us
because that's what human nature
demands and so um
i that's why that's why i don't want to
go to a place where we are saying
this is the end of liberalism or the end
of
free society i think we should just
um how else it's like aging yeah
yeah yeah liberalism will forever be
challenged we just have to be aware
and conscious of that and even after
radical islam is defeated walkism is
defeated
like so national socialism was defeated
and all sorts of other fascistic ideas
but it's not going to go away something
is going to come
in a new disguise that will be new to
the people who will be living through
that time yeah you know it's interesting
when i talk about sort of the end of the
road for liberalism what
what it means to me is that now i feel
that i can do
much more work helping to liberalize or
or even use some libertarian principles
with my conservative friends that seems
like a smart place to put energy for me
as opposed to trying to fix the woke
part of this thing but i think this is
the challenge for
for all of the liberals at the moment is
is sort of which way do you go
which way do you go well what i'm seeing
is yes you have to find
allies and alliances and um
if you so first of all we have to go
back to you know the american
uh americans
call classical liberalism they call it
conservatism
and the europeans just call it
liberalism because that's where it all
emerged
um in any case i think and the most
important thing for all of us to do
right now is
find that center ground
talk people who are on the center left
or center right
and make this attempt once again
to marginalize the fringes and the
extremists
and in in that sense i share your
concern
that the center is kind of sagging right
now
and we have to make these huge efforts
to go back there go back to sanity
our work is cut out for us my friend
let's get our
word out for us all right so i want to
talk uh obviously about the book
and two things before we get into the
sort of fill the full
part of it but on the opener of the book
on the very first
page you issue a trigger warning and i
thought that that was
that was quite interesting it says this
is a trigger warning
for the entry book reading it you should
be
triggered now a lot of my audience is
going to say wait a minute we don't like
trigger warnings on these things
why put a trigger warning on such a book
well it's a proclamation to take on
the woke and some of the people who
actually don't even know that they are
walk
or that they've subscribed to this
ideology
um and
it's also my way of saying
that if we want to go back to the center
in other words if we if we want to
address
some of the most confounding issues
of our day uh that you have to go back
to that
table and in good faith and say
and be open and honest these are the
problems we are having
now what we've seen i work you know i'm
an academic
i'm in the academic space um we are
constantly bombarded
with um
you know you have to to be mindful of
and sensitive to um students
feeling unsafe about this and unsafe
about that and microaggressions and
so the the work ideology that used to be
fringe
it has now become mainstream
points where you know at stanford you
just get all these emails that are
telling you
what you can and can't do what you can't
and can't say
there's more political and philosophical
activism in a way that i have never seen
before
and so i think you then start with
i'm actually taking this on i want to
trigger you
i think you go to school you go to
university
to learn how to think to address
you know when you're admitted to
university
there is an assumption that you're a
grown up
ready to take on the world and take on
all sorts of challenges that come your
way
if you are demanding a safe space
it's you know it was amusing a few years
ago
mildly yeah monthly right
now it's just downright creepy if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell